OF HOPE LIKE, YOU CAN SEE IT
CLOSELY, IT’S AT THE END OF THE
TUNNEL.
COMPANIES IN THE UNITED STATES
AND ELSEWHERE ARE STEPPING UP
AND RETOOLING OPERATIONS TO TURN
OUT MEDICAL SUPPLIES, HAND
SANITIZERS, VENTILATORS AND MORE
HELP FOR ALL OF US TO FIGHT THIS
CORONAVIRUS.
MORE PEOPLE, AND THIS IS REALLY
GOOD, OR GETTING TESTED EVERY
DAY BETWEEN MARCH 2ND AND
MARCH 14TH, 10.4 MILLION LAB
TEST WERE PUT IN THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM.
45,000 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TESTED
FOR THE CDC.
I KNOW ALWAYS COMPLAINING ABOUT
THE CDC BUT 45,000, 63,000 HAVE
BEEN TESTED BY COMMERCIAL LABS,
20,000 AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF MORE ARE COMING IN THE NEXT
WEEK.
LOOK, THE PRESIDENT WANTED
RESULTS.
HE GOT THEM, AND HE GOT THE ONE
SECRETARY OF HUMAN HEALTH
SERVICES, ALEX AZAR TO PUSH FOR
THIS.
I’M -- ALONG WITH THE DEAL
REGULATORY PUSH.
>> >> LARGE TESTING BY
LEVERAGING ALL SYSTEM.
THE ESTIMATED NUMBER OF OPTIONS
OF SUPPLIES, WE ARE STANDING ON
47 SITES IN 12 STATES.
>> HERE ARE SOME OTHER PROMISING
NEWS ABOUT KOVIC 19’S MORTALITY
RATE.
CHECK THIS OUT, USING A SLEW OF
PUBLIC AND INFORMATION, THE
RESEARCHERS SAY THE PROBABILITY
OF DYING AFTER COVID-19 IN WUJAN
WAS 1.4%.
NOW, WE DON’T WANT ANYONE TO
DIE, BUT THAT IS 50% LOWER HAS A
MORTALITY RATE THAN PREVIOUSLY
REPORTED IN MANY DIFFERENT
OUTLETS.
LET’S HOPE THAT NUMBER HOLDS
OVER TIME, ESPECIALLY AS MORE
PEOPLE ARE TESTED WORLDWIDE.
EVEN THOUGH ASYMPTOMATIC.
BUT PERHAPS THE BEST NEWS OF ALL
IS ABOUT A DRUG I BROUGHT TO
YOUR ATTENTION ON MONDAY NIGHT.
NOW AT FIRST, IT SEEMED TO ME
ALMOST SKEPTICAL, ALMOST TOO
GOOD TO BE TRUE, BUT THE RESULTS
FRANCE, CHINA AND BEYOND HAVE
BEEN NOTHING SHORT OF IMPRESSIVE
IMPRESSIVE.
>> WHAT IF IT IS ALREADY A CHEAP
AND WIDELY AVAILABLE MEDICATION
THAT IS ON THE MARKET TO TREAT
THE VIRUS?
ACCORDING TO A NEW STUDY, THERE
IS SUCH A DRUG.
IT IS CALLED CHLOROQUINE.
ALL OF THESE ANTIVIRALS HAVE
BEEN SHOWING PROMISING AND EARLY
TRIALS, AND THE ANTIVIRUS FOR
THE TREATMENT, NOT THE VACCINE
THAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT.
>> WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL, LAURA
THAT WE DON’T ASSUME SOMETHING
WORKS ON AN ANTIDOTAL REPORT
THAT IS NOT CONTROLLED AND VERY
SPECIFICALLY,
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
YOU HAVE BEEN GREAT ABOUT
CALLING THIS DRUG.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ADAMANT THAT
WE LEAVE NO STONE UNTURNED,
THERAPIES, CURES, VACCINES FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: TODAY, "THE ANGLE"
PERSISTENT PAID OFF.
THE PRESIDENT MADE THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> A DRUG CALLED CHLOROQUINE AND
SOME PEOPLE WOULD ADD TO IT,
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
IT IS KNOWN AS A MALARIA DRUG.
IT HAS BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG
TIME AND IT IS VERY POWERFUL.
IT IS SHOWN TO BE ENCOURAGING,
VERY, VERY ENCOURAGING WITH
EARLY RESULTS.
AND WE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT DRUG AVAILABLE ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY.
>> NOW AFTER THIS HAPPENED, THE
DRUG COMPANY DONATED
3 MILLION OF THE BILLS ON THIS
PARTICULAR DRUG TO THE DRUG
ADMINISTRATION.
AND ALTHOUGH THE FDA HAS NOT
APPROVED THE DRUG FOR USE AS A
TREATMENT FOR COVID-19, DOCTORS
CAN STILL PRESCRIBE IT.
>> THAT IS A DRUG THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS DIRECTED US TO
TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT AS TO
WHETHER TO EXPAND THE USE OF IT
TODAY.
IT COULD BE DONE.
SO WE CAN, WE WANT TO DO THAT IN
A SETTING OF CLINICAL TRIAL,
LARGE PRAGMATIC TRIAL TO GATHER
THAT INFORMATION.
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION THAT
NEEDS TO BE ANSWERED.
>> Laura: I HAVE A FEELING
GIVEN THE FACT THAT MOST OF THE
COUNTRIES ARE LOCKED DOWN RIGHT
NOW, THE CONTROLLED STUDY OF
2,000 PATIENTS COULD BE
ORGANIZED PRETTY QUICKLY, GIVEN
WHAT IS AT STAKE HERE.
AUNT IF YOU ARE LOOKING AT
VOLUNTEERS, I WILL VOLUNTEER.
THE FDA NEEDS TO HOP ONTO THIS
PRONTO.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE.
AND SEEING THE PRESIDENT SNAPPED
HIS TEAM INTO ACTION, IN THE
PROCESS, HARNESSING THE FULL